zone Europe
avec le soutien financier du Fonds
citoyen franco-allemand bonsoir et
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro de zone
Europe sur Radio sensation et sur TV 78
un numéro spécial réalisé avec le
soutien du Fonds citoyen franco-allemand
cette émission est consacrée au pompier
nous sommes d'ailleurs à la caserne
d'achat Facebook une ville jumelée avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye l'occasion de
découvrir ce métier et les liens qui
unissent pompiers français et pompiers
allemands
on va s'intéresser à la solidarité
européenne maintenant on se souvient que
cet été des pompiers de plusieurs pays
de l'Union européenne et notamment
d'Allemagne sont venus prêter main forte
aux sapeurs-pompiers français en Gironde
gros plan sur le mécanisme européen de
protection civile avec la Maison de
l'Europe des Yvelines Centre Europe
directe de Saint-Germain-en-Laye le
mécanisme européen de protection civile
ou MEPC créé en 2001 et piloté par la
Commission européenne ce mécanisme a
pour objectif de favoriser la
coopération entre les autorités
nationales de protection civile des
différents pays européens ils regroupe
actuellement 33 pays 27 pays de l'Union
européenne et 6 pays tiers Islande
Monténégro Norvège Serbie l'ancienne
République yougoslave de Macédoine et la
Turquie qui se coordonne pour apporter
leur aide aux victimes de catastrophes
d'origine naturelle et humaine en Europe
mais aussi dans le monde entier il est
déclenché à la demande d'un état et le
centre de coordination de réaction
d'urgence de l'Union européenne ou
emergines series coordination Center
organise la mise en commun des
ressources matérielles expert équipe de
terrain modules d'intervention proposé
par les États membres en capacité de
répondre la commission quant à elle
finance le fonctionnement général une
partie des frais d'acheminement la
formation des exercices préparatoires et
les opérations de sensibilisation de la
population
le RCC et le coeur opérationnel de ce
mécanisme il suit les événements qui se
produisent dans le monde sept jours sur
7 et 24 heures sur 24 le MEPC comporte
depuis 2019 une réserve européenne de
protection civile c'est-à-dire une
réserve de ressources affectée de
manière volontaire en vue d'un
déploiement immédiat au sein ou en
dehors de l'Union flotte d'avion et
d'hélicoptère avions d'évacuation
sanitaire équipe médicale d'urgence et
hôpitaux de campagne réserve de matériel
médical et capacité de laboratoire
mobiles capacité de détection de
décontamination et de stockage
permettant ainsi de réagir aux incidents
chimiques biologiques radioactifs et
même nucléaire des abris provisoires des
moyens de transport et logistiques doté
d'un nouveau règlement adopté en 2021 et
visant à renforcer ses capacités il est
intervenu à plus de 600 reprises depuis
sa création et plus récemment pour la
crise sanitaire liée à la covid 19 le
tremblement de terre en Haïti les le
patrimo en provenance d'Afghanistan la
guerre en Ukraine et les incendies de
forêts en Europe
bonjour Marc weigunt bonjour merci de
nous recevoir ici à la caserne d'achat
fendberg vous en êtes le chef alors
quand on compare les pompiers français
et les pompiers allemands on peut voir
une première différence d'abord en terme
d'effectif selon les chiffres en 2020 la
France compte 252
000 sapeurs-pompiers alors que les
Allemands en compte un million 345000
alors la différence se fait surtout sur
les pompiers volontaires l'écart semble
immense il y a un million de pompiers
volontaires en Allemagne contre 200 000
chez nous en France pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a autant de pompiers volontaires
en Allemagne
évidemment en Allemagne on a un autre
système qu'en France nous possédons un
réseau très dense de pompiers
volontaires aussi pour des raisons
économiques car il ne nous coûte pas de
salaire
et en plus avec ce système de pompiers
volontaire on profite beaucoup de la
densité des casernes ici en Allemagne
ce sont des systèmes différents mais la
qualité est la même
alors une autre différence entre les
pompiers français et les pompiers
allemands c'est sur le choix stratégique
des casernes en France le choix a été
fait d'éparpiller un petit peu partout
les casernes pour intervenir plus
rapidement alors qu'en Allemagne c'est
plutôt l'autre option qui a été choisie
avec des casernes centralisées qui a
raison entre les Français et les
Allemands
nous avons quand même un bon réseau de
caserne oui si nous sommes dans la
caserne centrale d'un shopping bourg ici
se trouve tout le matériel important il
y a aussi quatre autres caserne plus
petites avec peu de matériel qui sont un
peu plus éloignés pour pouvoir
intervenir le plus rapidement possible
je vous propose d'écouter maintenant le
capitaine Emmanuel blé tu commandant de
la caserne de Saint-Germain-en-Laye il
nous explique les différences de mission
entre les sapeurs-pompiers en France et
en Allemagne en typiquement en France
nous avons des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et volontaires qui
effectue exactement les mêmes missions
qui ont exactement les mêmes statuts
d'un point de vue opérationnel et qui se
rendent sur les mêmes interventions
aujourd'hui en Allemagne nous avons des
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels
qui vont intervention ce qu'ils ont des
gardes postées donc ils vont en
intervention en primo-intervenants et
ensuite les sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
sont rappelés sont rappelés au centre de
secours et viennent en renfort en
deuxième volet en deuxième engagement
pour venir effectuer des missions de
soutien de des blé de surveillance par
exemple alors oui il y a des différences
mais aussi certains points communs que
l'on aimerait parfois ne pas voir en
Allemagne aussi les pompiers se font
parfois agresser c'était le cas cette
année lors d'une Nouvel An une trentaine
de pompiers de policiers ont été blessés
par des pétards dans la capitale à
Berlin alors ça a beaucoup fait parler
ici en Allemagne qu'est-ce que vous vous
en avez pensé
les brutalités et les actes de violence
contre des forces d'intervention sont
inacceptables et nous les condamnons
nous sommes bouleversés par les
violences à Berlin lors du Nouvel An il
y a eu des violences aussi dans d'autres
villes allemandes
si les forces d'intervention sont
violentées alors même qu'elles sont là
pour aider les gens ça ne va pas du tout
il faut que ça soit puni
il est très important que la société
entière le comprenne et qu'elle nous
soutiennent il faut que ces violences
soient condamnées par la société
quels sont les principales missions qui
vous occupent ici à la caserne d'achat
fenbourg
sont des assistances techniques sur les
accidents des dégâts des eaux et le
soutien des ambulances les incendies ne
représentent seulement qu'un quart de
nos interventions
on l'a dit l'Allemagne compte énormément
de sapeurs-pompiers volontaires alors
ici si j'ai bien compris c'est une
caserne où il y a des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels combien de pompiers
travaillent ici dans cette caserne
ici dans la caserne il y a 90 pompiers
professionnels et environ
170 pompiers volontaires
active
en terme de matériel alors on a pu voir
on a pu apercevoir des camions mais
aussi des bateaux quel est le matériel
dont vous disposez ici pour aller faire
vos interventions
d'une quarantaine de véhicules
d'intervention
de 20 remorques et d'équipements
spéciaux pour différents cas de sinistre
comme des matières dangereuses du
sauvetage aquatique ou du sauvetage en
hauteur
vous le savez la France a été victime de
nombreux feux de forêt dans le Sud-Ouest
alors des pompiers venus de toute
l'Union européenne sont venus en renfort
pour aider leurs homologues français
vous en tant que pompier qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de cette initiative
et plus précisément la Bavière
certaines de nos équipes sont
intervenues en Europe pour aider des
pays frappés par des dégâts importants
comme ça a été le cas en France
récemment
ça peut parfois être compliqué
d'intervenir sur un autre territoire que
l'on connaît pas forcément comment
est-ce que vous vous adapteriez si
jamais demain vous devriez intervenir
dans un territoire que vous ne
connaissez pas
à l'étranger c'est d'avoir un
responsable local qui nous accompagne et
nous explique les conditions locales
c'est important d'avoir cette personne
qui nous aide et nous montre les
difficultés
comme c'est un territoire inconnu
les échanges entre les casernes de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et d'achat fenburg
sont réguliers on écoute tout de suite
le lieutenant Fabien de labre Lopez les
échanges dans le cadre du jumelage avec
les pompiers de bois consiste à des
rencontres
culturelles professionnels diverses
échanges ou des pompiers d'achat funburg
viennent à Saint-Germain à l'occasion
des différentes cérémonies et différents
échanges amicaux et fraternels que nous
pouvons avoir avec eux et des ça fait
envie de Saint-Germain seront également
en Allemagne à shuffenburg où nous
sommes à chaque fois accueillis des rois
à faire des activités extraordinaires et
surtout voir une des une façon de vivre
et de travailler avec un peu différente
c'est toujours très enrichissant pour
nous lorsque vous êtes venus en France
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus marqué
ce qui nous impressionne toujours le
plus
c'est l'accueil de nos collègues et amis
français
on peut toujours échanger malgré
certaines barrières de langues
et de l'autre côté lorsque les pompiers
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye viennent ici à
achaffenborg qu'est ce que vous voulez
leur transmettre en priorité
nous voulons promouvoir la ville d'achat
Facebook et promouvoir notre région
nous leur montrons la culture allemande
nous faisons beaucoup d'excursions
on essaie de varier le plus possible le
programme
par exemple une fois nous sommes allés à
la fête de la ville
entre les pompiers français et allemands
sont un exemple parmi d'autres de
l'amitié franco-allemande a pucé vous le
savez depuis 1963 et le traité de
l'Elysée des échanges qui sont
enrichissants comme en témoignent
l'adjudant chef Michel clavier de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour moi
personnellement vu l'histoire
l'historique entre la guerre entre les
Allemands et les Français
moi j'ai connu ça donc mon père était
prisonnier de guerre et je trouve ça
formidable de relouer les liens et de
faire une croix sur le passé
mon père a connu a été prisonnier de
guerre Et maintenant d'aller là-bas et
d'être copain de fraterniser avec eux
pour moi c'est c'est je trouve ça
vraiment formidable vu l'histoire qu'il
y a entre les deux pays entre la France
et l'Allemagne avoir des contacts aussi
forts avec des pompiers français
qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour vous
il est très important de ne pas
complètement oublier l'histoire qui lit
nos deux pays et c'est notre devoir de
construire une amitié étroite d'avoir
des échanges amicaux et de sa porter
mutuellement du positif
[Musique]
va avoir lieu dans cette caserne ici à
achat fenber pour célébrer le 60e
anniversaire du Traité de l'Elysée alors
comment est-ce que les pompiers se sont
préparés pour cette journée
on ne l'aura pas donné à manger pendant
trois mois
ce sera
mais ils ont bien compris de quoi il
s'agissait
ou en tout cas on a hâte de voir le
résultat merci beaucoup Marc de nous
avoir reçu ici dans la caserne à
[Musique]
c'est une journée un peu particulière
pour la caserne d'achat finborg les
pompiers allemands vont poser
aujourd'hui devant l'appareil de Fred
Goudon Fred Goudon c'est le photographe
des Dieux du stade et de plein d'autres
calendriers il est spécialiste dans
l'art de photographier le corps des
hommes
[Musique]
ça y est on le rejoint Fred Goudon alors
Fred il y a besoin de quoi pour un
shooting alors il faut des flashs du
matériel qui est là et puis tous les
pompiers qui sont en train de se mettre
en place donc on a fait un petit un
petit discours de bienvenue ça s'est
bien passé et après ça on va commencer à
ajouter petit à petit les uns après les
autres individuellement pour leur donner
un petit peu l'idée de ce que ça donne
et puis pour moi aussi avoir une idée de
leur photo génie et puis après on va
enchaîner sur les photos de groupe etc
bon laisse fret se préparer et puis nous
on va aller mettre une tenue un petit
peu plus adaptée
[Musique]
ça y est maintenant on est dans le thème
c'est l'heure de la traditionnelle photo
de groupe
alors une belle photo de groupe
mais c'est ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose ils font ils font encore on voit
que ils sont tous en place et en plus
ils se connaissent bien et donc je pense
que ça se ça se voit là mais ça se verra
encore plus à l'image
Corentin à toi maintenant à moi de jouer
[Musique]
est-ce que tout le monde est photo
génique non la photo génie c'est
vraiment ses propres à chacun et alors
des fois il y a des gens ça ils sont
très beaux et ils rentrent pas du tout à
la photo et puis des fois c'est
l'inverse où les gens sont un peu
disgracieux peut-être ou en tout cas et
on dirait pas mais quelquefois ça rend
vraiment très très bien à l'image donc
peut-être que vous me voyez là moi je
suis très photogénose
vraiment faire ce shooting le
photographe est vraiment cool et nous
nous amusons beaucoup ensemble avec tout
le groupe les photos sont incroyables de
ce qu'on a déjà pu voir
au total ce sont près de 1500 photos qui
ont été prises aujourd'hui attends il va
falloir faire des choix et puis les
sélectionner pour pouvoir les exposer au
public prochainement en France
zone Europe
bonjour Fred Gounon bonjour Corentin je
vois que la caserne d'achat fendbrooke
vous a adopté vous avez vous portez
maintenant ce son t-shirt vous êtes
photographe c'est vous qui avez réalisé
4 fois le célèbre calendrier des Dieux
du Stade alors chaque année des femmes
s'arrachent vos calendrier il faut dire
que vous êtes spécialiste dans l'art de
photographie le corps des hommes alors
quand ce n'est pas des rugbyman c'est
des pompiers comment est-ce qu'on
explique cette fascination pour le
métier de pompier alors c'est vrai que
c'est un déjà c'est un très beau métier
et les pompiers justement
s'entretiennent physiquement donc ça
correspond complètement au type de
modèle que j'aime bien photographier et
comme je dis toujours c'est un pompier a
une belle tête un beau corps et un bon
esprit peut faire partie de mon
calendrier alors en 2023 a l'air du
numérique l'aspect
utile du calendrier un peu disparu on a
tous nos calendriers sur nos téléphones
alors pourquoi est-ce que les ventes
continuent et pourquoi est-ce qu'on
achète encore ces calendriers c'est la
photo qui qui est vraiment l'objet que
l'on achète oui c'est beaucoup plus
l'objet que le calendrier je pense que
le calendrier est devenu un prétexte
avoir une belle photo accrochée sur un
mur et surtout avoir une photo voilà qui
change une fois par mois donc alors
sincèrement des fois quand elle plaise
elle reste plusieurs mois la même c'est
pas grave mais justement c'est l'image
qui prime plus que le plus que les dates
alors cette fois vous nous préparez une
exposition itinérante dans les Yvelines
à l'hôtel de ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye à la Maison de
l'Europe au crazyo la
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et même dans
les locaux de Radio sensation une
exposition donc pour célébrer l'amitié
franco-allemande est-ce que avant ce
projet vous connaissiez déjà l'Allemagne
est-ce que vous avez déjà été dans ce
pays et qu'est-ce que l'amitié
franco-allemande représente pour vous
alors oui j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
un éditeur allemand avec qui j'ai fait
mes premiers six livres d'ailleurs donc
c'est pas c'est pas un petit truc c'est
un éditeur de Berlin qui s'appelle Bruno
blender et donc j'ai l'occasion d'aller
plusieurs fois à Berlin justement pour
les rencontrer j'avais organisé aussi
l'exposition à Berlin dans un hôtel à
l'hôtel Axel c'était vraiment une
superbe aventure et puis j'ai vraiment
ça se passe toujours très très bien avec
les Allemands je trouve qu'il y a une
chose qui se passe simplement
naturellement efficace ils font ce
qu'ils disent ils sont c'est un vrai
plaisir de travailler avec eux vraiment
et donc de travailler pour cette avec
cette association voilà ça m'a permis
d'avoir tout à fait envie de le faire
immédiatement spontanément et avec
plaisir vraiment et donc la
multiprrancolement est-ce que vous
l'avez vécu aujourd'hui au cours de ce
shooting on va en parler ah oui
clairement on a été accueilli
extrêmement bien tous les pompiers qui
étaient là vraiment étaient bien briefés
avait envie d'être là ils ont pris du
plaisir à faire ce qu'on a fait
apparemment ils étaient contents du
résultat parce que j'ai pu leur montrer
justement ce qu'on avait fait et
franchement ça a été une journée
exceptionnelle émouvante exceptionnelle
et vraiment avec un bon esprit alors
aujourd'hui justement vous avez pu
travailler dans une caserne de pompiers
directement ici à achaffenburg est-ce
que c'est un lieu de travail habituel
pour un photographe comme vous alors une
caserne directement pas parce que
justement en France c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué
souvent des casernes proposées de venir
travailler et faire les calendriers dans
leur lieu et puis après finalement quand
ça monte un petit peu dans
l'administration dans la hiérarchie
sûrement par des problèmes des questions
internes ou d'assurance ça s'avère un
peu plus compliqué que ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui où on était vraiment
tellement chaleureusement accueilli
simplement on avait carte blanche je
pourrais aller où on voulait faire ce
qu'on voulait enfin c'était vraiment une
grande chance alors cette caserne vous
l'avez j'imagine visiter un petit peu
avant de de travailler quels sont les
lieux que vous avez repéré comment
est-ce que vous vous y prenez pour c'est
le coup de cœur c'est le coup de coeur
le coup d'oeil pour repérer un lieu
particulier c'est un petit peu tout et
je demande avoir plein de choses parce
que c'est vrai que par moment
quand je vais faire un repérage les gens
pensent que une partie de ce lieu va mal
aller complètement alors qu'il y en a
une autre qui est peut-être un peu plus
vieille un peu plus décati un peu
usé par le temps et là c'est là où je
vais être très content donc j'ai un peu
surprenant peuvent être de bons lieux
pour un bon spot comme on dit absolument
et c'est vrai que ça s'avère aujourd'hui
on a fait des photos incroyables dans
des lieux qu'on n'aurait pas soupçonné
pour avoir une photo aussi belle et
importante donc c'est le moyen justement
de je me projette et il faut absolument
que je voie lieu pour me projeter sinon
je voilà je peux pas je peux pas juste
un exécutant et faire l'image on dit de
la faire il faut que je vois tout ce que
vous avez un exemple de lieu là à nous
d'écrire qui vous a particulièrement
marqué aujourd'hui mais tout à l'heure
on était entre deux lieux de shooting
dans les vestiaires en bas et une salle
de sport et entre les deux on est passé
devant une machine riz avec des énormes
tuyaux un peu rouillé etc et voilà
j'étais j'étais comme un fou de voir ça
parce que ça rendait extrêmement bien et
donc on a fait une très belle photo dans
ce lieu entre deux voilà mais ça
parfaitement alors je sais que ça va pas
vous rajeunir mais ça fait 38 ans que
vous avez débuté votre carrière de
photographe quel est le plus beau lieu
dans lequel vous avez travaillé ah il y
en a beaucoup mais je pense que c'est le
premier justement j'ai commencé à faire
des photos en Californie dans une petite
ville entre Los Angeles et San Diego qui
s'appelle San clémente et donc c'est là
où j'ai commencé à faire mes premiers
photos de modèles vraiment et ça m'a
permis justement de commencer ma
carrière et de travailler après pour des
agences parce que ce que j'ai fait
pendant très longtemps c'est de faire
des boucs de mannequins d'une manière
professionnelle dans plusieurs endroits
dans le monde et beaucoup aux États-Unis
en France alors on sait chaque secteur
évolue en 38 ans est-ce que les codes de
la photographie ont changé ce qu'il a
fallu s'adapter j'imagine au nouveau
code aujourd'hui il ne cesse de changer
après c'est vrai que le numérique a été
vraiment la partie la plus la plus
spectaculaire dans l'évolution de la
photo
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir m'y adapter
facilement parce que je suis un artiste
avant tout et peu importe le moyen
finalement qui compte c'est la finalité
et c'est vrai que le numérique m'a
permis justement d'aller certainement
au-delà de ce que je faisais en
argentique mais au début c'était
fastidieux compliqué
et puis finalement voilà ce qu'il faut
c'est travailler finalement travailler
pour un du résultat et c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec avec le numérique et
puis aujourd'hui bien sûr cette
évolution de cette image qui envahit nos
vies avec les réseaux sociaux alors
c'est vrai que un moment Instagram je
considérais que ça prenait beaucoup
beaucoup de de mon énergie de mon
travail et que les autres faisaient des
photos qui étaient pas mal finalement et
son nez les réels sur Instagram ou Tik
Tok par exemple qui sont plus des images
vidéos que des photos donc ça permet de
remettre en avant un petit peu mon
travail de photographe finalement parce
que les gens font beaucoup de vidéos et
c'est très bien comme ça donc au cours
de votre carrière vous avez côtoyé de
nombreux pompiers comment est-ce qu'on
sont les pompiers allemands aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que ça s'est passé est-ce
qu'ils sont prêtés aux yeux ah oui mais
vraiment et puis sans se connaître
voilà ce matin on les connaissait
absolument pas et puis ce soir on est
parti avec des gens avec qui on a passé
une journée incroyable et avec un
c’était extrêmement de chaleureux avec
des remerciements de leur part qui m'a
vraiment troublé et une gratitude
vraiment par rapport à ce qu'on a fait
et c'était vraiment très très content de
ça et puis moi aussi d'ailleurs je suis
je suis joie de ce qui m'ont apporté et
surtout la confiance qui m'ont porté et
pour finir Fred Goudon quel est votre
technique pour les mettre à l'aise s'il
y a eu besoin de les mettre à l'aise
alors oui il faut toujours quand même
les mettre en confiance qui que ce soit
quelle que soit les modèles que l'on
photographie bon
mon quotidien c'est de faire du nu
artistique donc j'ai l'habitude de le
faire c'est pas un sujet pour moi et
j'amène justement les modèles à savoir
poser naturellement nu alors il faut
absolument qu'ils aient envie de le
faire je force jamais personne à faire
quoi que ce soit comme aujourd'hui on a
fait une scène sous la douche on a
vraiment proposé voilà à qui voulait le
faire bon c'était du nu de dos donc
c'était voilà ça reste juste esthétique
il y a rien de provoquant mais voilà il
fallait que chacun arrive à se projeter
par rapport à cette photo et finalement
il voulait tous les faire oui donc et
j'avais besoin de trois ou quatre
pompiers seulement pour faire pour faire
cette photo mais parce que justement je
pense que ils se sont sentis en
confiance et ce que j'arrive à générer
facilement c'est-à-dire que comme quand
vous allez chez le médecin finalement
vous mettez ou torse nu ou nu c'est sans
complexe c'est naturel etc et donc je
pense que j'arrive à provoquer ça chez
les modèles que je photographie en
général merci beaucoup Fred boudin merci
Corentin d'avoir été avec nous puis on
attend le résultat et puis cette
exposition à venir
son Europe
zone Europe chez les pompiers c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui vous pouvez
revoir cette émission en replay sur
notre site Internet et sur notre
application radio sensation et aussi sur
tv78 merci au fond si toiien
franco-allemand allez Pascal maintenant
faut y aller
avec le soutien financier du fond
citoyen franco-allemand
[Musique]